if you take humans as a species it's a
group species and that means that the
well-being of the individual human is
inseparable from the group this presents
an issue with socialization because our
survival as humans is so linked to our
connection to other people that we
actually will pray play like this
internal triangulation game so as to
stay connected with the people upon whom
our life depends if i was to take a tiny
infant and if i sc to go put them
outside they're dying
we are so completely dependent for so
long and even when we are able to meet
our needs technically our well-being is
still dependent upon connection with the
group triangulation is essentially where
i try to establish closeness to the
exclusion of so we see this in our
social groups like michelle she was like
totally unfair to you just then so it's
it's a way to sort of push somebody away
so as to develop rapport and we have
this exact same relationship dynamic
going on but in the internal world and
this is where self-hate begins